bonsoir à tous
j'espère que vous êtes encore réveillé
ce fait longtemps que vous êtes lâchés
le dernier donc encore un peu de
patience et après on pourra discuter de
tout ça ensemble dans les salons
derrière je voulais commencer par une
question est ce que vous vous rappelez
de napster napster
c'est le premier site internet sur
lequel on s'est échangé gratuitement de
la musique sur des fichiers mp3 ce
fameux format fichiers mp3 rappelez-vous
à l'époque ni maisons de disques hurlait
on allait tuer la musique qui je me
rappelle d'un numéro de science et vie
micro d'un magazine qui traite des
nouvelles technologies qui titrait déjà
à l'époque l'économie du peer to peer
le prochain rarement le prochain
raz-de-marée alors qu'est ce que c'est
que l'économie du peer to peer
dans le même numéro pascal [ __ ] le
président d'universal music disais oh la
la le peer to peer
ce sera un épiphénomène qu'est ce que
c'est que le peer to peer
c'est tout simplement l'économique
l'aîné particulier en particulier qu'il
une économique est né grâce au web qui
nous permet du coup de nous connecter
les uns aux autres hyper rapidement et
en masse au même moment à la même époque
mon amoureuse ombeline travail dans un
label de musique qui un jour elle rentre
à la maison et me montre myspace vous
rappelez tous de myspace sur myspace on
y voit pour la première fois des
centaines et des milliers d'artistes
indépendants qui s'exposent qui
partagent des choses des sons des images
des paroles des bouts de vie et puis on
voit aussi en même temps des communautés
or le mot est connu aujourd'hui à
l'époque ils n'étaient pas des
communautés online s'installer autour de
ces artistes qui aussi se mettaient à
propager sur les réseaux sociaux qui
venait de naître
la carrière de ces artistes donc on
assistait à l'époque à la naissance de
deux phénomènes les réseaux sociaux et
les communautés facebook est arrivé
juste derrière avec le succès que vous
connaissez ongles il me montrant ce
phénomène me dit on pour un temps un
artiste en particulier d'ailleurs me dit
si on demande à cette communauté 10 20
30 40 ou 50 euros pour financer l'album
où le concert où le club vidéo de cet
artiste il ya quand même de grandes
chances que tout le monde soit passionné
par ça et là en tant que fan de musique
je n'y vais la raison dont deux duos si
on se met d'un seul coup à financer des
artistes directement ton m
on est à l'aube d'un nouveau système de
financement pour la création billionaire
cet emblème déjà on est très tôt dans
l'histoire on venait à l'époque juste de
définir à peine ce qui allait devenir le
crowdfunding financement participatif
lendemain des jeunes et qu'adrien son
cousin un petit peu avec un parcours un
peu particulier qui avait à peine 20 ans
l'époque c'est un type qui a arrêté
l'école à 13 ans à 14 ans il était
acteur à 16 ans il était réalisateur 18
ans il avait déjà plié sa carrière dans
le cinéma et il y avait déjà monté sa
première agence de com se sert de rien
et en discutant avec adrien tous les
deux se disent mais si ça marche pour la
musique ce système ça marche forcément
pour plein de typologie de projets ça
marche pour le cinéma ça marche pour
tous les types de créateurs et
potentiellement ça peut même aller loin
plus loin que pour les créateurs on line
rentrer à la maison
ce soir-là fort de cette discussion est
là du coup en me racontant cette
discussion avec adrien je me dis mais il
ya quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer véritablement on est peut-être à
l'aube d'une nouvelle logique de
finances d'une nouvelle logique de
financement alors on a commencé à bosser
tous les trois d'abord un peu et puis
plus en plus et puis tous les week-ends
un an après en quitter notre job et en a
encore plus tard en 2008
on monte kiss kiss bang bang kiss kiss
bang bang aujourd'hui c'est devenu
leader européen du financement
participatif en septembre 2009 ont lancé
notre premier projet green shape qui
collectait 25000 euros pour financer son
album et puis petit à petit sont arrivés
sur la plateforme des réalisateurs des
designers des dessinateurs des écrivains
et puis des sportifs des humaine i cité
scientifique et on s'est retrouvé petit
à petit avec un univers qui n'est plus
en plus large
et pourtant pas tellement longtemps
avant les médias lorsqu'ils venez nous
rencontrer à l'époque nous aimaient ce
que vous avez monté c'est un phénomène
de mode ça durera pas pourquoi voulez
vous que les gens d'un seul coup entre
eux se mettent à s'échanger de l'argent
ça pas de sens ça durera pas très
longtemps
voilà on été très clairement mis dans la
case des utopistes
des alter mondialistes pour pas dire des
hippies madère et puis le système a
commencé à dérouler déroulé déroulé
déroulée et le meilleur exemple je crois
pour prouver l'efficacité de ce système
c'est le film de mélanie laurent et
thierry dion qui est venu un jour avec
un projet de film écologique nous voir
après cette fait rembarrer d'à peu près
toutes les boîtes de production de la
terre entière
on a décidé de travailler avec nous sur
ce projet et lorsqu'on a lancé ce projet
en quelques heures il avait collecté
50000 euros au bout de deux jours il
aurait collecté 200 mille euros et en
fait c'est un projet qui a collecté
quasiment cinq cent mille euros en
quelques semaines
alors pourquoi ça marche c'est simple
c'est qu'on nous a vendu l'idée qu'on
était des gens individualiste mais c'est
faux on est des animaux empathique par
définition sinon l'abitre est tous dans
les grottes individuellement il se
trouve que non on habite ensemble
sauf que la société telle qu'elle est
construite aujourd'hui nous poussent
dans des caves et souvent dans des cases
on se retrouve tout seul on obligé de se
battre les uns contre les autres pour
pouvoir grimper alors fort de ces
expériences magnifique convoyés sur kiss
kiss bang bang
on s'est mis à penser que peut-être le
monde allait se transformer à notre
image que on allait créer un petit peu
partout une harmonie nouvelles bases et
fondait sur une espèce de co-création
est co financement malgré tout on n'a
jamais été naïf on l'a toujours été à
l'écouté des gens qui sont aussi plus
pessimistes qui pense que
potentiellement le pire peut toujours
arriver
et malheureusement pour moi un jour le
ciel m'est tombé sur la tête
j'étais en train de lever des fonds pour
kiss kiss bang bang c'est toujours une
période hyper fatiguant par
l'entrepreneur d'ailleurs j'étais cloué
au lit à cause d'une douleur et je
reçois un coup de fil important pour moi
ça faisait deux trois jours que
j'attends des coups de fil de nos
nouveaux investisseurs pour valider le
fait qu'ils allaient rentrer au capital
de risque et en l'occurrence ils
m'appellent pour me dire c'est bon du
coup ma grippe peuvent passe à la trappe
comme quoi ce n'est pas une grosse
grippe quand même et je trouve un regain
d'énergie j'appelle ombeline ai je dit
écoute nos investisseurs vont être
capitales et du coup je vais te
rejoindre ce soir au concert ou encore
les programmes et ensemble c'était
concert de dingle savent death-metal
jeter le pressent dans l'orne 2015 au
bataclan
on est arrivé à quatre concerts ombeline
mois et de nos meilleurs potes on est
sortis que tous les deux vivent mais pas
indemme complètement évidemment on a
déménagé nos enfants dans le sud ouest
depuis je fais des allers retours on
been va mieux nos enfants grandissent
correctement et nous on s'accroche on
s'accroche à ce qu'on voit tous les
jours sur kiss kiss bang bang
on s'accroche à une vision du monde qui
peut être différente
et pourtant je vous garantis que parfois
c'est pas simple c'est à dire que se
dire tous les jours qu'on construit
quelque chose pour une amie une humanité
meilleure dans ces conditions là c'est
un petit peu compliqué mais ma famille
mes amis mon équipe sur kiss kiss et les
milliers de créateurs de projets qui
viennent sur kiss kiss m'aide à tenir le
coup à tenir le coup parce que
l'humanité quoi qu'il en soit toujours
traîner derrière elle son lot de
violence de cruauté et l'injustice et
pour autant on peut pas s'asseoir par
terre se mettre à pleurer et dire que
les choses vont s'améliorer ou encore
pire que les choses sont toujours comme
ça il faut bien continuer à bouger alors
c'est ce qu'on l'a fait continuer à
bouger et continuer à bouger
ça veut dire croire en ce qu'on nous
propose aujourd'hui et ce qu'on nous
propose aujourd'hui est multiple on a
toutes les technologies qu'on veut pour
sortir de notre dépendance vis-à-vis des
énergies fossiles et donc reconstruire
l'économie
on a toutes les technologies qu'on veut
pour connecter l'intégralité de la
planète à internet
on a toutes les technologies qu'on veut
pour partager cette éducation sur toute
la planète on a toutes les technologies
qu'on veut peut-être même pour combattre
la vieillesse on a toutes les
technologies qu'on veut potentiellement
pour nous envoyer sur d'autres planètes
et ça c'est un fait
aujourd'hui kiss kiss à 7 ans et donc
pour nous c'est dans on a décidé de
regarder en arrière et de mesurer
l'impact
l'impact économique et social de cette
année d'activité donc on a interrogé
notre millions de membres ainsi qu'ici
c'était une ville en serait la deuxième
plus grande ville de france
et voilà ce qu'on a vu en réponse alors
les chiffes basique on connaît nous on a
collecté plus de 70 millions d'euros
pour plus de 15 mille projets on a
permis la création de plus de mon quasi
3000 associations ou entreprises
on a permis également la création de
plus de 15000 contrat de travail soit
des cdi soit les cdd soit des heures
d'intermittents du spectacle on a réussi
également
l'exploit de fabriquer grâce à vous
grâce à nous grâce au public et grâce au
créateur plus de soixante mille heures
de contenu soit produit soit diffusé
c'est des milliers de disques des albums
de musique sont des milliers de pièces
de théâtre sont des centaines et des
centaines de bouquins ce sont un tas de
projets comme ça qui porte notre vision
et qu'il apporte aux alors évidemment le
marché du crowdfunding c'est pas que
kiss kiss bang bang ce marché comme une
traînée de poudre s'est mis à caracoler
partout dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui on connaît les chiffres le
marché était à zéro en 2007
en 2015 on était à presque 35 milliards
d'euros collectés en 2016 on sera à plus
de 70 milliards collectés dans le monde
sa double chaque année ce qui veut dire
qu en 2020 on aura dépassé les 1000
milliards d'euros collectés donc fini
évidemment dans ce cadre là les rumeurs
d'utopie fini les altermondialistes fini
les hippies souvent maintenant j'entends
même qu'on ait des visionnaires as quand
même dingue de passé si vite d'un alter
mondialiste un visionnaire mais c'est
comme ça moi je m'en tamponne ce qui
compte vraiment pour nous c'est cette
énergie qui sort de kiss kiss bang bang
cette énergie qui nous pousse parce que
cette énergie elle est d'un optimisme à
comparables elle est d'une fille khalid
et sans nom et elle est en même temps un
lien commun entre nous qui est
formidable et je sais pas si vous le
ressentez mais moi je le ressens au
quotidien on est aujourd'hui à l'aube
on a les moyens de reprendre le pouvoir
sur notre créativité grâce à ce genre de
système on est donc à l'aube de
reprendre le pouvoir sur notre argent
on est donc un lot de pouvoir reprendre
le pouvoir sera destiné cette force
cette énergie
ça s'appelle l'intelligence collective
et cette intelligence collective
elle est là devant vous devant nous
notre rôle aujourd'hui c'est de la
propager que la cuisse qui se force soit
avec vous merci
[Applaudissements]